hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from the second
day of the Champions Chester finals
Wesley so versus Magnus Carlson this is
the first game it just finished and like
yesterday Wesley also started with Pawn
to B3 uh but they didn't go in the exact
same variation Wesley already switched
it up on move three so Wesley starts off
with 1 B3 and Magnus goes for G6 same as
he did yesterday and remember since
Magus WS won the previous match Wesley
needs to be beat him now in this match
in four game match to force um a third
match so let's see what happens G6
Bishop to B2 Knight to F6 and in the
previous game Wesley started with Pawn
to C4 but here we have Pawn to G3
switching it up sort of the Indian
variation of the N solaron attack uh
Bishop to G7 and now Pawn to C4 uh we
have castles and now Bishop to G2 Pawn
to D6 and now Wesley goes for Pawn to E3
which is very interesting as you'll see
later on uh so Magnus strikes with E5 we
have Knight to E2
preparing or rather it seems like he's
preparing to advance the pawn to D4 Rook
to E8 and now Knight B to C3 we have
Pawn to C6 and now uh well uh people
thought that either Wesley will play D4
here or he was going to Castle maybe
then play Pawn to D4 but no he played
Pawn to E4 so he sort of Wast the tempo
here by playing Pawn to E3 and then to
E4 but of course uh he knows what he's
doing and here we have Pawn to A6 by mag
so now Wesley does have full control
over the D5 Square everything controls
that D5 Square so it's very unlikely
that Magnus will be able to execute D5
so he organizes a different um uh
Central breakthrough he plays A6 and now
he wants to challenge Wesley Center with
Pawn to B5 uh and okay we have castles
here uh and uh well there is a game
where A4 was played but castles is a new
move so now already as of move 10 we
have a completely new game Magnus
strikes with Pawn to B5 we have Pawn
Pawn to A3 and now Knight B to D7 uh we
have Pawn to D3 and Magnus goes for Rook
to B8 The Rook will be very strong here
and also the bishop on B2 is undefended
so Wesley plays Rook to B1 and now
Knight to C5 just being a menace here
and putting pressure on B3 and D3 uh
Bishop back to A1 Now The Rook also
helps out with the defense of the B3
pawn and now B captures on C4 uh we have
B captures Rook captures on B1 uh Queen
captures and now Bishop to E E6 and
Wesley plays Rook to D1 uh in hopes of
executing Pawn to D4 but it's not going
to be easy to do that with the uh
weakening of the C4 and of the C and D4
pawns and okay now Magnus has to figure
out how to get um the most out of the
position he can either offer a queen
trade with Queen B8 or maybe something
like Queen to C7 followed by Rook to B8
he goes for the immediate Queen trade as
Magnus most often does we have Queen to
C2 Wesley avoids the queen trade and now
Queen to B3 now if you don't want to see
Rook B1 you have to ensure that the
trade happens so Queen to C1 Wesley
again declines it but also has to defend
the A3 pawn and now Magnus goes Knight F
to
D7 uh we have Pawn to D4 uh for the
moment you cannot capture on C4 as the
Knight on C5 is hanging but still e
captures on D4 Knight captures we have
Bishop captures Rook captures now Wesley
goes after the D6 Pawn as well but not
to be worried as Magnus goes Knight to
E5 and it looks like you're just giving
up the uh D6 Pawn for the C4 Pawn but
not really Rook captures on D6 is played
but now Magnus goes for Knight C to D3
attacks the queen but also takes care of
the B2 Square which means that he kicks
away the only defender of the A3 Pawn so
he traded the D6 Pawn for the A3 pawn
and now he has the outside pass a pawn
that he will try to push to Victory so
Queen D1 now wle offers a queen tra but
of course just Queen captures on A3 we
have Pawn to C5 uh and now we have
Bishop to B3 putting more pressure on
Wesley's Queen we have Queen to F1 and
now Bishop to C4 the position is already
uh very much winning for Magnus but he
doesn't want to waste too much time
since Wesley is has a minute and 24
seconds but here I move like Knight to
C1 I would Ure Magnus of victory since
the bishop on B1 Bishop on A1 can't
really be saved you can play something
like Knight to B1 in order let's say
queen captures on A1 then Queen captures
on C1 but now comes Knight to e to check
and it doesn't matter if the queen
captures or not uh you will pick up the
bishop on A1 now the Knight is hanging
and after you move the queen back now
just Bishop C2 and that's it you lose a
piece here end the game uh but Magnus
went for Bishop to C4 now he's
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries so Knight to E2 stopping
that and now just Queen captures on C5
and now grabbing a pawn and now you will
start advancing the past a pawn to
Victory Rook to D4 uh Queen to A3 by
Magnus and now Pawn to a H3 creating
some breathing room for the white king
Knight to C5 and now Queen to C1 now
Magnus offers uh sorry now Wesley offers
a queen trade Queen captures we have
Knight captures and now Bishop to B5 so
Magnus didn't get um as much out of the
position as it was possible but look at
his clock time he's already down to 6
seconds uh so playing completely un
increment and Wesley also not that great
on time he has 30 seconds in the clock
we have Pawn to F4 uh Knight to C4 and
now Pawn to E5 we have Knight to E6
trying to blockate those pawns and Rook
to D7 Wesley promotes his Rook to a pick
but what good will it do him we have
Pawn to C5 by Magnus uh Rook to D3 and
now Pawn to A5 now the past a pawn
starts marching forward Rook to B3 goes
after the bishop H but Magnus doesn't
defend the bishop he just plays Rook to
d8 H with some uh uh 3 seconds on the
clock uh so Rook to D1 check is the
threat he wants to to go after the
Knight and here Wesley should have
traded objectively it's a draw but um um
you know you have to play perfect with
very little time on the clock he went
for Knight to D3 instead and now Pawn to
A4 this comes with Tempo so now he
captures and now Magnus captures on D3
we have Rook to B8 with check King G7
now Rook to B1 uh we have Rook captures
on G3 grabbing yet another pawn and when
Wesley saw this he you could see visibly
that uh uh he was just incredibly
frustrated and he has given up on this
game so King to H2 was played attacking
magnus's Rook Rook back to A3 and now
Pawn to F5 with have G captures on F5
and now Rook to G1 now Wesley has to
rely heavily on tactics maybe to survive
this King f8 uh Rook to C1 but you could
see it in the way that he was moving the
pieces that he you know even even his
hands have given up we have Knight to E3
uh Bishop to C6 now uh putting pressure
on that A4 Pawn but it will do him
little good we have Knight to D4 attacks
the bishop uh Bishop captures on D4 now
uh the pass C Pawn becomes a pass D Pawn
we have Bishop to B5 and pawn to F4 now
now three of magnus's pass pawns are
Marching forward uh Rook to C8 with
check we have a king to G7 and now a
rook to C7 trying to go after that uh
Pawn maybe also E6 will be very nice so
Rook to A2 with check King to A1 King to
H1 and now King to G6 now so if E6 you
can simply capture it uh we have Bishop
to D3 with check King to G5 and now Rook
captures on F7 so Wesley also creates a
pass Pawn uh but Magnus is just much
faster Rook to D2 and now Wesley says
all right I can't really do anything
here now Magnus will start pushing the a
pawn so I have to give up the bishop in
order maybe to try and Advance my pass
Pawn to Victory so he plays E6 and the
Magnus calculates precisely Rook
captures on D3 and now Wesley plays Pawn
to E 7 and now I could ask you to pause
the video here but if Magnus allowed it
you guys know what the idea here is do
you see how black wins the
game uh I'm sure I'm sure you do even
without pausing the video as you guys
are incredible players uh of course the
idea is Rook to D1 check and then you
just put the Rook on E1 and stop
promotion problem is the white King has
only one square that is the H2 square
and now Knight to F1 with check forces
the king um back doesn't matter where
you go to uh if you go to G2 Rook to E1
if you go to G1 Rook to E1 uh whatever
you play so King to G2 was played now
Rook to E1 and the queening square is
covered Wesley tried King to F2
attacking The Rook H but Magnus just
gives back the Knight and says I will
keep continue uh I will keep um guarding
the queening square you can have the
Knight so there's nothing better Wesley
takes the Knight on F1 Now Pawn to A3
and the pawn is Unstoppable H4 check but
Magnus doesn't care about it you could
even capture it it's still winning
Magnus just plays King to G4 and he was
in this position on move 59 that Wesley
so resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so it's a really
really tough loss for Wesley as it's um
it's a you know a match he was supposed
to bounce back in and he starts by
losing the first game with white where
he chose Pawn to B3 denino Larson he did
it also in the previous match but in
that game he was able to get a draw H
not so lucky today uh so yeah here we
resign because after a few checks let's
say Rook G7 check King F3 there's
nothing you cannot do anything just um
A2 A1 or even you can just Checkmate the
white king doesn't really matter you can
push this Pawn uh pretty much any move
you win any move you make will win you
the game and if something like Rook to
G8 let's say A2 you can even allow
queening because then uh you can bring a
queen or you can even bring a rook it
will still be Checkmate doesn't matter
uh so yeah and also something very
interesting that fa said after the game
that um while B3 okay maybe it can be
considered a great opening and maybe you
can even do wonders with it is just not
an opening that you will um that that
you can use the Hostile Magnus against
Magnus you need to put constant pressure
and you need need to constantly be
attacking him and maybe then he will Rak
but if you play a slow opening like B3
you pretty much leave it up to him like
you say okay uh this is very flexible I
have all the all the positions in the
world in front of me but that kind of
favors Magnus not you uh so that that
was um sort of Fab's idea uh and it
seems that he he is definitely on point
there so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it we'll see what happens in the
rest of the match and we'll Wesley be
able to bounce back we'll cover those
games as well I would like to thank
Robert arathun Sims joh toris farm at
the Night Before Christmas good luck on
law school finals canv and Benjamin
hyberger for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have excellent
rest of your
day